this is varosha marash in Turkish it's
been a ghost town since 1974 when people
fled to escape conflict Greek cypriot
livelihoods and homes were lost along
with Lifestyles of the Rich and those
with modest incomes the towns been
sealed off from Time by its captors in
the Turkish cypriot North but for the
past two years people have been allowed
back into the town again just a small
part of it mainly tourists on day trips
there are exceptions like Andreas
Lourdes but for now he can only look at
his property
he was six years old when his father's
Hotel was hit by a rocket-propelled
grenade one of the first losses in a
multi-million dollar business Empire
we have suffered and needed Leslie for a
half a century were undergoing a
humanitarian crisis of being locked out
of our houses every day
there is no ostensible reason for these
to be happening and the two sides can do
better but can they improve things
tourists are coming here in increasing
numbers attracted to a place that was a
holiday choice of 60 Stars such as
Richard Burton Liz Taylor and Sophia
Loren but this isn't just about business
politics are at the heart of what's
going on here
varosha has long been a bargaining chip
in failed talks to get a settlement in
the Frozen conflict of Cyprus the
self-declared Republic of Northern
Cyprus had offered the return of the
town to Greek cypriots as part of a
federation but now the Turkish cypriot
leaders here favor a two-state solution
which changes the situation
Greek cypriots they rejected all the
plans we had proposed before if they had
said yes they would enjoy the ownership
here so somebody should
bring this place to the usage of the
International Community to the usage of
the uh and enjoyment of the private
owners
the Turkish cypriot's plans have been
condemned by the U.N it has reasserted
that view only legal owners should be
allowed to reclaim their properties the
future for varosha looks like the failed
attempts at a peace deal for Cyprus
unsettled and divisive Andrew Simmons Al
Jazeera Borussia